how was it working on curb probably this
probably the second or third greatest
moment of my life in comedy did you have
a script or was it improv does everybody
know curb and you don't have to say Curb
Your Enthusiasm yeah I think everyone
everyone in our world knows for sure but
curb was you know auditioning it was so
fun because I was supposed to go in for
this role for uh uh there's if you've
seen the episode the last season was
there's a guy with a dog named Adolf
yeah do you remember that episode where
he's like why would you name it Adolf
he's like it's a family name and man and
Larry but so they wanted me to do that
so I went in there with like a German
accent
and it crushed and then Larry told
Allison who casts the show who put me in
the office she put me in a bunch of
stuff
she was like he he was like he he
doesn't look Aryan Duty as red hair like
this one we want a guy that looks like a
Hitler boy you know like this guy isn't
gonna that's not gonna work
so I was a little bummed because they
talked about it like right in the room
and then Larry was like I want but I
want him in some I want him to do
something so they they had this other
character they were building the latte
Larry's uh which is a competition for
you know if you've seen the show you
should watch the show but and they said
they want this like construction worker
to help construct this like perfect
urinal for Larry and so Allison gave me
the character description and then sent
me in the hallway and she's like We're
going to take some other auditions for
the Hitler dog guy but you know do you
want to come back later today and I said
no just give me like three minutes to
read this and I'll come back so one guy
read
I you know came back in the room and
Larry was like what are you doing here
and I was like I'm ready and she was
like you don't want any more time I was
like no I'm good and then I improv with
Larry and I made him break like three
times and he was like get the [__] out
of here and then I knew I just knew when
I got in the car I knew because he kept
laughing in the middle of the thing and
then was like just get get out of here
and when he kicked me out I knew I was
like all right we're good yeah it was
Rad but I did some of the beats that I
did in the show like one of the things I
did on that I actually duplicated that I
improved in the room that I took to the
show was
JB's move
saw it was me and was like oh so oh
what's up sir and then immediately was
like I'm gonna get in the scene and he
just like got in the scene because we
were you know doing jokes about having
your dick near the urinal and the one
joke that landed in the room that I did
was he was like how how was this wall
gonna know and I was like we'll have a
dick detector immediately when you walk
up to it it'll detect your penis size
stature it'll know how far you need to
be from the toilet and the door will
slide up and it'll go dude penis
detected and Larry broke in the middle
of the room started dying laughing and
he's like dude do the do the noise thing
again do it again and so I was doing all
these different robot sounds for the
pisser and he I knew on the day he was
like bring all that [__] to the thing so
we did you know
I don't know
20 minutes of takes and then that was my
day I mean it was lightning fast it was
just like go go go go go go go go and
then you're done you're it's super quick
because they improv they improv one big
scene Larry goes no to that yes yes no
yes no and then you do it again and then
he goes yes to that no bring that other
thing back and then one more and by that
the third take you really are like
whittling it down to almost it's like
writing a good joke it's like you
Whittle it right down to it trim all the
fat yeah and he broke a few times which
was huge like it was nice to make him
laugh but I was diligently working on
not laughing at JB because maybe one of
the funniest people I've ever seen live
in my entire life like he just is so
good at that character on that show and
making up just chaotic nonsense you know
like he was talking about how like what
side of what side of the pants that your
your penis is on dictates what kind of
man you are anyone on a whole rant about
that and I was it was just so funny it
never even made it into the cut but from
that Larry took a piece of that to do
something house and that's how they work
like they're little comedy magicians he
like takes a thing moves the thing puts
it here there but he see I think he
knows every single beat he really wants
to end up at but he lets you find it a
little bit on your own that's crazy he
said he's the greatest comedic producer
performer I've ever worked with live in
my life by far did Bobby have that same
experience because I because I didn't
realize Bobby was the Korean bookie on
like season three yeah yeah and I mean
was he said Bobby was having a panic
attack the entire time and yeah knowing
what to do but he did he did good though
do you like shopping on Amazon I do and
good news is Stevo's butt wipes for your
butt wall are available on Amazon and if
you want a real bundle of a deal you can
get Stevo's hot sauce for your butthole
plus Stephen's butthole destroyer and
Stevo's butt wipes for your butthole
it's the butthole bundle available on
Amazon right now
yeah dude